egal ob schräge Diäten oder fragwürdige
Fatburner Pillen nichts wirkt bis jetzt
denn eine neue Klasse von Medikamenten
die eigentlich zur Behandlung von
Diabetes entwickelt wurde sind das erste
funktionierende abnehmmedikament Experte
nur mit Experten sprechen schon von
einer Revolution der Medizin klingt zu
schön um wahr zu sein aber ist
tatsächlich Realität in Deutschland
werden sie schon verschrieben in etwas
über einem Jahr verlieren Menschen mit
starkem Übergewicht so um die 15% ihres
Körpergewichts aber bei all der Euphorie
kann es denn wirklich so einfach sein
präsentiert sich da wirklich gerade die
Lösung für eines der größten
medizinischen Probleme unserer Zeit wie
nachhaltig ist der Gewichtsverlust
wirklich und könnten diese Medikamente
noch viel mehr Krankheiten behandeln
genau darum geht es heute bei dr Watson
[Musik]
okay als allererstes ein Missverständnis
nervt mich bei dem Thema wirklich immer
übergewicht kann nämlich verschiedene
Ursachen haben die nicht immer in der
Hand der Personen selber liegen der
Zugang zu Gesundheitssystemen
verschiedene Lebensumstände und unsere
Umwelt spielen genauso eine Rolle wie
genetische Faktoren und ja Änderungen im
Lebensstil also gesunde Ernährung und
ausreichend Bewegung sind zwar ein
Grundbaustein des gewichtsmanagements
führen aber häufig nur zu einem
schwachen Gewichtsverlust der schwer zu
halten ist das liegt auch an
langfristigen Veränderungen im Körper
etwa im Sättigungszentrum im Gehirn oder
an Entzündungsprozessen aber jetzt kommt
der Hammer es gibt nun ein Mittel das in
genau solche körperlichen Prozesse
eingreift bevor wir über die Probleme
davon sprechen und ja Spoiler die gibt
es worum geht's eigentlich lass uns mal
zurück ins Jahr 2018 gehen als ein
Medikament namens osempic von der
Europäischen Arzneimittelbehörde immer
zur Behandlung von Typ 2 Diabetes
zugelassen wird
zu Hause es geht also erstmal nur um
Diabetiker der Wirkstoff dieses
Medikaments Sema glutid hilft dabei den
Blutzucker zu regulieren indem er sich
genauso verhält wie eine Form des
körpereigenen darmhormons in kritin das
nennt man GLP 1 der Wirkstoff ist dem
GLP 1 so ähnlich dass er an den dafür
vorgesehenen Rezeptor bindet deswegen
nennt man diese Medikamente auch GLP 1
Analoga oder in krithin nimetika also in
Kritik Nachmacher quasi bei gesunden
Personen wird GLP 1 vor allem nach dem
Essen ausgeschüttet und stimuliert unter
anderem die Abgabe von Insulin wodurch
dann der Blutzuckerspiegel singt nice
ist aber nicht genug GLP 1 vorhanden
wird dieser natürliche
Regulierungsprozess gestört Wirkstoffe
wie Sema Gluten die so tun als wären sie
GLP 1 können Diabetikern also helfen
diese Nachmacher können aber noch mehr
denn noch während die klinischen Studien
mit Diabetikern liefen wurde klar dass
Sie nicht nur Ihren Blutzucker senken
können sondern nebenher auch noch ihr
Gewicht die inkritinen mimetika Binden
nämlich nicht nur an die Rezeptoren im
Darm sondern auch im Gehirn im
Hypothalamus so aktivieren Sie bestimmte
Neuronen naja diese hier dadurch sinkt
das Hungergefühl während das
Sättigungsgefühl steigt kurz gesagt sie
verringern den Appetit und das Verlangen
nach fettigen Energie reichen
Lebensmitteln und setzen damit genau da
an wo viele abnehmen Versuche scheitern
seitdem haben die Unternehmen hinter dem
Medikamenten einige Studien mit stark
übergewichtigen Menschen ohne Diabetes
durchgeführt und das hat funktioniert
wenn auch eher so semi gut ein Wirkstoff
namens Lira Gluten konnte z.B über 56
Wochen einen durchschnittlichen
Gewichtsverlust von etwa 8% bewirken
immerhin über 5% Punkte mehr als ein
Placebo umgehauen hat das zwar keinen so
wirklich aber basierend auf Lira Gluten
ein Wirkstoff entwickelt der nicht so
schnell abgebaut wird und länger im
Körper bleibt und dieser Wirkstoff sehen
wir glutid hat dann so richtig gut
funktioniert so gut dass er unter
Experten als absoluter gamechanger gilt
und auch so gut dass Social Media
komplett eskaliert aber dazu gleich mehr
die Experten beziehen sich mit dem
gamechanger vor allem auf eine Studie
von 2021 darin wurde untersucht wie gut
sie Magnetit in Kombination mit einer
Ernährungsumstellung und ausreichend
Bewegung stark übergewichtigen Personen
beim abnehmen hilft in knapp 15 Monaten
konnten die Teilnehmer ihr Körpergewicht
durchschnittlich um 14,9 % reduzieren in
der Placebo Gruppe waren es gerade mal
2,4 % Sema Gluten wirkt also und könnte
das Leben von hundert Millionen von
Menschen nachhaltig verändern wie bei
jedem Medikament gibt es natürlich auch
Nebenwirkungen am häufigsten treten
Übelkeit und Verdauungsprobleme auf das
hält sich durch eine langsame Dose
Steigerung aber in Grenzen insgesamt
aber überwiegt der Nutzen gegenüber dem
Risiko die EMA hat simaglutid deswegen
unter dem Handelsnamen wegowy schon zur
Behandlung von Übergewicht zugelassen
voraussetzung ist ein BMI von über 30
oder von 27 wenn gewichtsbedingte
Begleiterkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck
vorliegen wenn ihr mehr über den BMI
erfahren wollt und wir so er trotz
starker Kritik in der Medizin
tatsächlich noch verwendet wird könnt
ihr euch dieses Video hier anschauen
wieso wie ist mittlerweile sogar schon
ab 12 Jahren zugelassen und die
Anwendung ist ziemlich einfach einmal
wöchentlich gibt man sich selbst eine
Spritze es funktioniert wie diese epipes
die ihr vielleicht von Allergikern kennt
für Diabetiker gibt es immer Gluten auch
in Tablettenform für Übergewicht ist das
aber noch nicht zugelassen
okay das klingt ja fast perfekt oder
verlässlich abnehmen ohne sich diese
ganzen Gedanken um das eigene Essen zu
machen das wahrscheinlich der Traum von
Millionen von Menschen alleine hier in
Deutschland aber so einfach ist es dann
doch nicht denn bevor jetzt direkt in
die nächste Arztpraxis sprintet Stopp
ihr werdet wie govi wahrscheinlich nicht
bekommen denn der Wirkstoff ist gerade
Mangelware der Hersteller Novo Nordisk
hat schon Probleme bei der Produktion
für Diabetiker hinterher zu kommen wir
haben mal nachgefragt und die Firma hat
uns gesagt dass die Produktion zwar
schon ausgebaut wurde man mit einer
weltweit so starken Nachfrage aber
einfach nicht gerechnet habe tja wer
hätte gedacht dass ich Leute für das
erste verlässlich funktionierende
abnehmen Medikament interessieren nur wo
nur das kann wahrscheinlich nicht denn
obwohl wieso wie bis vor kurzem in
vielen Ländern noch gar nicht erhältlich
war wurde sie immer Gluten der Wirkstoff
während der ganzen Zeit schon zum
Abnehmen verschrieben und zwar in Form
von ozempel in Vigo wie steckt der
gleich Wirkstoff wie govi enthält nur
viel mehr davon um den GLP 1-rezeptor im
Gehirn anzusprechen braucht es nämlich
etwa doppelt so viel Simon glutid wie
für die Diabetesbehandlung nötig statt
Figur wie können Ärzte also auch
musempic bei Übergewicht verschreiben
das ist dann zwar nicht die optimale
Dosis aber es funktioniert und zwar so
gut dass das komplette Internet voll von
Erfolgsstories ist der
#usempic hat allein auf tiktok etwa 1,2
B Aufrufe Billionen Billionen klingt
etwas viel wahrscheinlich ein
Übersetzungsfehler von tiktok den
billion ist im Deutschen eigentlich
Milliarden egal und wenn dann noch
Promis wie ihnen Mast twittern wie toll
sie abgenommen haben danke dann schafft
das immer mehr Aufmerksamkeit und immer
mehr Menschen die ihre Ärzte aktiv um
die abnehmen Spritzen bitten die nehmen
dann damit ab berichten dann auch wieder
online und in den Medien darüber und so
weiter und so fort ihr seht es ist ein
Teufelskreis der maßgeblich zu den
Lieferengpässen beiträgt die Nutzung
außerhalb der ursprünglichen Zulassung
nennt man übrigens oft Labels Zahlen
dazu liegen uns leider nicht vor aber
wir wissen das verglichen zum letzten
Frühjahr 74% mehrosempic Spritzen
verkauft wurden die Diabetesfälle in
Deutschland steigen zwar seit Jahren
aber so stark dann auch bei weitem
wieder nicht und daraus ergibt sich ein
richtiges Problem denn der
off-labeleinsatz gefährdet aktuell die
Versorgung von Patienten mit Diabetes
Typ 2 und die brauchen dieses Medikament
und stehen dann in der Apotheke
teilweise vor leeren Regalen das haben
uns auch einige unserer Zuschauer und
Ärzte im Hintergrundgesprächen bestätigt
von dem Off Label use von osempic wird
deswegen von zuständigen Behörden dem
Hersteller selber und von vielen anderen
Experten abgeraten
[Musik]
daraus ergibt sich ein ethischer
Konflikt wer ist eher berechtigt ein
Medikament zu bekommen wenn es gerade
nicht genug davon gibt denn auch
Patienten mit starkem Übergewicht und
Begleiterkrankungen die von der
Gewichtsreduktion profitieren würden
haben ja ein Recht auf Therapie
adipositas ist eine chronische
Erkrankung und keine persönliche
Entscheidung und das muss ich klar
betonen eine Therapie mit Sema glutid
richtet sich nicht an Leute die mal ein
paar Kilo verlieren wollen es geht um
Menschen die bereits seit Jahren
versuchen Gewicht zu verlieren dass ihre
Gesundheit signifikant beeinträchtigt
und selbst wenn wir irgendwann in
simaguität schwimmen sollten bleibt es
höchstwahrscheinlich ein Medikament für
stark übergewichtige Menschen und kein
Lifestyle Produkt und selbst wenn das
Medikament alleine reicht nicht die
Patienten müssen trotzdem ihre Ernährung
umstellen und sich ausreichend bewegen
und auch mit möglichen Nebenwirkungen zu
recht kommen für einen nachhaltigen
Gewichtsverlust wird auch zu einer
Verhaltenstherapie geraten denn wer die
nutzen irgendwann absetzt bei dem kehrt
sofort der Hunger von vorher zurück
erste Studien zeigen dass viele der
Patienten direkt wieder zunehmen und
genau aus diesem Grund möchte ich mit
euch mal über Kalorienzählen sprechen
ich selber habe mich die längste Zeit
meines Lebens als zu dick betrachtet und
darunter lädt man Selbstwertgefühl und
auch noch viele andere Dinge die sich
dann im Januar 2021 beschlossen habe
abzunehmen das habe ich schon häufiger
beschlossen aber damals hat es dann auch
tatsächlich funktioniert denn ich habe
Kalorienzählen gemacht das passt zu mir
das muss nicht zu jedem passen aber bei
mir hat es gut funktioniert weil das
eine sehr akkurate und wissenschaftliche
Methode ist um abzunehmen und die App
die mir damals erlaubt hat über 16 Kilo
abzunehmen heißt ja so damals hatte ich
überhaupt keinen Kontakt zu der Firma
dahinter aber ich war davon begeistert
und diese Begeisterung beruht auf
Gegenseitigkeit anscheinend denn ja so
hat sich entschieden dieses Video hier
zu unterstützen die App kann eine Menge
ist aber ziemlich easy zu verstehen
erstmal gibt die an was ihr wiegt und
was ihr gerne wiegen würdet daraus
berechnet ja sie dann wie viel Kalorien
ihr jeden Tag zu euch nehmen solltet und
wenn ihr wirklich nur das esst dann
werdet ihr abnehmen versprochen dank der
großen Datenbank könnt ihr dann einfach
alles was sie den Tag über est per
Barcode einscannen oder eintragen da
müsst ihr natürlich sehr akkurat sein
ich habe mir dann noch ziemlich schnell
yazio pro geholt weil das noch mal mehr
Features hat zum Beispiel
intervallfasten was mir persönlich viel
geholfen hat was ich aber damals nicht
hatte war ein rabattling von Dr Watson
über 50% für ein Jahr yazio pro über
diesen Link hier yazio Punkt / Watson
bekommt ihr yazio pro für fast nur 2 €
im Monat abnehmen hat mein Leben
verändert und ja so hat mir dabei
geholfen wenn ihr euch auch die App
runterladen wollt dann klickt auf den
ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung und da bekommt ihr
nicht nur den Rabatt sondern findet auch
meine persönlichen fünf Tipps zum
Abnehmen ich wünsche euch ganz viel
Erfolg dabei und jetzt zurück zur
Kontroversen die jetzt Spritze ein Punkt
der mir noch wichtig ist ist die
Kostenfrage denn das Zeug ist verdammt
teuer in den USA liegt der Listenpreis
für eine Mon Informationen wie go wie
bei umgerechnet um die
1230 Euro also fast 15.000 Euro im Jahr
und klar man kann jetzt sagen die
Amerikaner Spinnen mit ihrem
Gesundheitssystem und damit hättet ihr
auch recht aber auch in Deutschland ist
das ganze nicht gerade billig und das
ist problematisch denn selbst wenn Vigo
wie bald zuverlässig erhältlich ist darf
es nicht von der gesetzlichen
Krankenkasse übernommen werden laut
sozialgesetzbuche sind Arzneimittel mit
denen vordergründig eine Erhöhung der
Lebensqualität bezweckt wird von der
Versorgungspflicht ausgeschlossen ergo
die Kasse zahlt nicht darunter fallen
auch Medikamente zur Zügelung des
Appetits und zur Reduzierung des
Körpergewichts wie wiegovi das steht im
Widerspruch dazu dass Adipositas nicht
nur von den Fachgesellschaften sondern
auch vom Bundestag als Krankheit
anerkannt ist die Patienten müssen also
selbst für die Therapiekosten ihrer
anerkannten Krankheit aufkommen was ich
persönlich sozial extrem ungerecht finde
dazu kommt dass sich der
gesellschaftliche Druck abzunehmen noch
weiter erhöhen könnte weil ganz viele
Menschen rumlaufen die jetzt dünner sind
das ist nicht nur problematisch für
Menschen die sich eine Therapie nicht
leisten können oder nicht dafür geeignet
sind sondern auch für die die
Medikamente einfach nicht wollen weil
sie gesund und glücklich mit dem Gewicht
sind dass sie haben da vigovi seit
kurzem auch in Deutschland erhältlich
ist sollte sich jetzt immerhin das
Problem mit dem off-label use einstellen
die Lieferprobleme bleiben aber bestehen
bis es genügend Produktionskapazität
gibt daran wird gearbeitet also alles
eine Frage der Zeit die verglichen mit
den 20 Jahren in denen auch so ein
Medikament hingearbeitet wurde er kurz
ist und immer gluten ist erst der Anfang
es gibt bereits einen weiteren Wirkstoff
Tier sepatit der nicht mehr nur an den
Rezeptor für GLP 1 sondern auch an den
für GIP bindet diese duale Wirkweise
funktioniert bei Personen ohne Diabetes
sogar noch besser als sie mal Gluten und
auch bei stark übergewichtigen
Diabetikern die wegen ihrer Erkrankung
oft besonders mit dem Abnehmen kämpfen
ist die Partie überlegen für Adipositas
läuft in den USA bereits ein
beschleunigtes Zulassungsverfahren für
Typ 2 Diabetes ist es schon zugelassen
und surprise zeitweise auch von
weltweiten Lieferengpässen betroffen
gerade wird sogar noch einen triagonist
getestet der einen dritten Rezeptor
anspricht und wahrscheinlich noch besser
funktioniert und die Studien in diesem
Gebiet überschlagen sich gerade es ist
wirklich spannend das gerade
mitzubekommen während die Wirkstoffe
immer besser werden erschließen sich
weitere Einsatzgebiete die Fachwelt
warte z.B gerade gebannt auf die
Ergebnisse einer Studie die die
Wirksamkeit bei Herzerkrankungen und
Schlaganfällen bestätigen soll auf die
starke Hinweise gibt und weil GLP 1 Teil
des Belohnungssystems ist könnten sogar
Menschen profitieren die mit dem Rauchen
aufhören wollen auch das wird gerade
getestet wer weiß vielleicht werden wir
in der Zukunft alle zu Perfektion
Menschen die keine Laster haben wir
werden von diesen Medikamenten also
definitiv noch mehr hören unsere
Redaktion bleibt auf jeden Fall dran und
ihr bleibt hoffentlich neugierig bis
dahin
Dreck
schaut euch gerne unser Video über
Gewicht an
Übergewicht Übergewicht ihr versteht den
Job
sondern auch für die die mich